[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEREMY JOHNSON: So it's
very bright up here.
I can barely see you.
I'm really excited
to be here today.
I hope you are too.
I hope everyone is
learning a lot today.
Before I get started, I'd
like to take just a moment
to thank the Next Event staff.
We can't do things
like this without them.
So let's all give a real
quick round of applause
for the folks who have
made this possible for us.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks.
That's awesome.
So the other thing I'd like
to do before I before I get
started, I'd like to remind you
to provide feedback for all the
for all the sessions that
you've attended today,
including this one.
And we use that
feedback to ensure
that future topics are relevant,
high quality, and compelling.
So please do take the
time to let us know
how you feel about the content.
Real quick about myself.
My name is Jeremy Johnson.
I'm a product manager
with Google Cloud.
I specifically
work on networking.
My primary focus in
product management
is around IP addressing.
And we are actually
doing a panel
on IP addressing tomorrow.
So please come at
9:00 AM tomorrow
and listen to IP
addressing talk as well.
I've been at Google for
about a year and a half,
and one of the
things that's really
awesome about working
at Google is working
with world class engineers.
I mean, I've worked with some
great engineers over my career.
I've been doing this
for about 25 years.
And I've really
honestly never worked
with such a great
group of people.
And it's my honor today to
present some of the work
that they've done
to create what I
consider probably the greatest
network on the planet.
And hopefully, I
can do that justice.
So our goals today
are really simple.
We're going to go over
our global network, which
if you've been following
the operations track,
you've probably heard a lot
about over the last couple
of days.
You're going to hear
more about it today.
We're also going to talk about
the Andromeda architecture,
which is our software
defined network
that operates our cloud.
It's not the only software
defined network that we run,
but it's the one we're
talking about today.
And then finally,
throughout the slides,
I'm hoping to get across some
of the practical benefits
of the architecture
and infrastructure
that we've put together.
So this slide probably looks
familiar to some folks.
And I hope it does.
We think this is
really important.
This is a view of
our global network.
And when you think
about Google's cloud,
it's important to think
about the global network.
The reason for that is that
everything we do centers
around this thing, this
global interconnected
network that we've built.
And we're pretty proud of it.
Some numbers for you.
We've got 20 cloud regions.
I think if you were here
last year, that number
was significantly smaller.
I think it was in the single
digit digits last year.
So we've been
expanding really fast.
Yeah, 125 pops.
The pops are where we
connect to the internet
and also provide Edge
network services.
Of those 125 pops, 90 of
them serve as CDN locations.
72 of them serve as dedicated
interconnect locations.
We've got 15 Google
data centers.
So not every region has
its own data center.
That might be a little bit
confusing, but trust me.
We've also got 26 renewable
energy project locations,
hundreds of thousands of
miles of fiber optic cable,
and 13 sub-sea
cable investments.
So we've put a lot into
this infrastructure
to make what we, again,
think is probably
the best network on the planet.
So the question, I guess, is
why does this really matter?
And to me it comes
down to two things.
It's less work for you all.
And it also provides
more options.
And what do I mean by less work?
When we think about
things globally,
and we offer you
global constructs,
you're able to do things
like create one VPC
globally without replicating
it across multiple regions
and then having to worry about
replicating configuration
and connectivity across
all those regions
and replicating all
of your policies
across all of those regions.
For us, it's one
global VPC, and we've
created things like the
shared VPC and host projects
so that you can
really leverage that.
We'll talk more about
that in a minute.
Also, we've created
a whole bunch
of services that work
both at the global level
and at the regional level.
So for example, some
of our global services
are things like layer
7 global anycast VIPs.
This provides the ability
to do load balancing
at a global level without having
to play games with DNS, etc.
We've got many interconnect
locations across the globe.
We also have differentiated
network tiers.
We've got what we call a Premium
Tier and a Standard Tier.
Actually, we've got
a booth outside that
shows kind of really
what's going on there.
But the difference between the
network tiers is really simple.
The Premium Tier leverages
the entire global network.
So your traffic can enter
our network anywhere,
and it can exit
anywhere in the network.
The regional services, or
the Standard Network Tier,
allows traffic to enter
in a regional location
or someplace approximately
close to a region, so the pops
nearby a region.
And also that allows traffic
to only exit those places.
And these are choices that
you might make based on cost.
You might make them based
on local rules or compliance
purposes.
So again, this is really
interesting and compelling
from my perspective, because
you've got more choices,
I think, with our
network and our cloud
specifically when it
comes to networking
than any other cloud.
So I'm sure you've all
seen that slide before
of the global network.
So I kind wanted
to give you an idea
of what really goes into that.
And so what we've got here is
a picture of one of the fiber
trench and several dozen
fiber ducts outside one
of our data center campuses.
And the thing that's
interesting about this
is that each one of
those orange pipes
has thousands of strands of
fiber just for that one campus.
And also, we've got
hundreds of thousands
of miles of global
fiber backbone.
One of the things that's
interesting about this backbone
is there's so much
redundancy built into it
that, we can lose
many connections
and still achieve
global reachability.
So again, this is also
the infrastructure
that powers Google.
So I think you're all well
aware of our commitment
to reliability of Google.
And I think, you
know, it probably
is obvious how much
of a problem it would
be if we lost connectivity.
So this is a major
part of our story.
So I'm going to
take the time now
to talk about some
network functions.
And the way we're going
to organize this is I'm
going to talk about
these network functions
at a somewhat high
level, and then we're
going to dig down
deeper into them
and talk about how we actually
make those things happen.
So it all starts
with this global VPC.
The idea of a global
VPC is that we
can have multiple clients
running on the same network,
using overlapping
network name spaces.
We all use 10.0 for something.
But they're all sharing the
same network infrastructure.
So this requires us to build
functional and performance
isolation for all for
all of our clients.
Oops.
I should be using that.
I don't know what
slide I'm on now.
I apologize.
So network functions,
we talked a little bit
about the global load balancer.
I want to talk about
it a little bit more.
So with a global network,
at those pop locations,
we're able to provide
load balancers that
present a single global
IP to all of your clients
across the world.
So one VIP with
the same IP address
serving the entire globe.
And the way that
we're able to do
that is we leverage a technology
called anycast, which really
means that we're
advertising the same IP
addresses at all
of our locations.
And we've IP'd your VIP
with that same IP address
at each one of those locations.
What this does is it attracts
traffic from our peers
to the most geographically
proximate ingress location.
And then from there, we
back haul that to whatever
cloud back end you
have serving it.
This enables you to do
global load balancing, again,
without manipulating DNS or in
fact taking sometimes signals
from DNS that are
potentially inaccurate.
So this slide is a bit
of a bit of a mess.
So I'm going to try and
walk you through it.
What we have here-- this is
an engineering conversation,
right?
You weren't expecting really
beautiful slides, were you?
So anyway, we're going to start
from, I guess, your right side
and walk it towards me.
So what we've got here
is a basic example
of a VPN using our
global network.
And again, this is about
choice and ease of use.
So let's say you've got
your on-prem network
and you've got this green VPN
termination device at your end.
You're going to
traverse the internet
with your IPsec tunnel.
And you're going to land
that at a VPN gateway
in a cloud region.
So when it lands in
that cloud region,
you've got some choices.
You can, first of all, just use
resources in that cloud region
and route back to that
VPN termination point
through that tunnel.
Or you can export the routes
using our cloud router
and also a toggle
called Global Routes
to route all the information
that your project learns
from the VPN globally.
And that's just a simple toggle.
So you can either isolate
your VPN endpoint locally,
or you can or you can
enable it globally.
Likewise you can advertise
your routes from Google,
that you learned from
Google, back across that VPN
connection, including any routes
that your VPC has globally.
And you do that with a
mechanism called Custom Routes.
And this is just
a small example.
Also, I've got in
there a layer 4 ILB.
The interesting thing about
that is that you can literally
use an internal load balancer at
the far end of a VPN connection
to load balance
internal traffic,
again, anywhere in the world.
And we're going to
talk a little bit more
about how that
works in a minute.
So the network load
balancer is interesting.
This is more of a
regional construct.
But the interesting thing
about the network load
balancers, it actually
uses our Edge pop
as well because this is for
public internet traffic coming
into a cloud region, but it's
not load balance at layer 7.
So when we talk about the global
load balancer, or the Layer 7
VIP, that does termination.
So it actually terminates
an HTTPS connection.
It terminates an SSL
connection or it proxies TCP.
This is actually a layer
3, layer 4 load balancer
that directs traffic to two
backends in a cloud region,
a specific cloud region.
So if you wanted to load
balance across multiple regions,
in this case, you would
actually deploy load balancers
in each region that you
wanted to load balance.
And so in this situation,
we've got Maya in California,
Bob in London, and
Shan in Singapore.
And a couple of the interesting
things about this load
balancing capability is that
we do preserve the client IP
address so that we can
do direct server return.
And also, it facilitates
creating firewall rules
on the cloud backend.
This is kind of important.
Again, to make things easy,
you have the same IP address
on your LB VIP, as you
do on your backend VIP.
And so it's just
one firewall rule
at the regional level to manage
security for those connections.
Another regional function--
and this one is more truly
regional--
is the internal load balancer.
We talked about it a little
bit in the case of the VPN,
but sort of how it
works is, again, it
allows you to create
an internal event.
But in this case,
it's completely
programmed in a distributed
fashion across our Andromeda
infrastructure.
There are no middle
boxes in this case.
In the other cases, the
global load balancer,
there's a middle box
that's doing termination.
In the network
load balancer case,
there's a middle box that's
actually that's actually
directing traffic at the edge.
It's something we call a Maglev.
Internally, in these
internal load balancers,
this is completely using the
distributed software defined
network that we've built. And
it's actually programming flows
directly onto each host.
And there are no middle
boxes to speak of.
Again, client IP
addresses are preserved.
It's easy to set it's
easy to control access
with firewall rules.
And we believe it offers
higher performance because
of no choke points.
Again, no middle boxes for
these kinds of load balancers.
So let's talk a little
bit about how it works.
So again, we talked
about that global VPC.
So remember, we've got to do
functional and performance
isolation.
And what that means is,
again, every project in cloud
is using the same
infrastructure globally,
but you're all operating
on different or distinct
isolated network name spaces.
So we all have overlapping
IP addresses basically.
But you're also all
expecting us to provide
performance guarantees.
And so we also have
to do isolation
at the performance level.
And then finally, we have
to offer high availability
to everyone.
So our high
availability targets--
and this is interesting--
we as a mnemonic called 3, 4, 5.
So if you deploy an
application in a single zone,
our target for availability
is three 9s of availability.
If you deploy across two
zones in the same region,
or regionally as
we would call it,
then you would expect
four 9s of availability.
And if you deploy
something globally
across multiple regions,
you should expect five 9s
of availability on our network.
We think, number
one, that's unique.
But, number two, that creates a
whole bunch of problems for us,
since if your application
availability needs
to be 3, 4, 5, that means
that what we're deploying
is actually 4, 5, 6.
So a unified view
of functions, this
is where I go to the note cards,
so bear with me for one second.
So where are we?
OK, so we wanted to spend
some time on the data plane.
And basically, the
message behind this slide
is that we've built the
core network functions
into the VM host themselves.
And that's a consistent theme
across the Andromeda network.
There's a constant
evolution of features
that we push out weekly.
And we can do this because
we support live migration
so that we can do
host maintenance
in a non-disruptive fashion.
And also, we can do hitless
upgrades of our data plane.
And we'll talk a
little bit about how
we can do that as well.
So the architecture
itself, first of all,
is replicated across regions.
It's sharded across regions.
And it's also
sharded across zones.
So what we've done
is we've basically
built a hierarchy
of a control plane
that manages a data plane.
So first up at the
top-- and you're not
going to see it in this slide--
is the Cloud Cluster Manager.
This performs a lot of tasks,
including configuring storage.
It also configures
compute and networking.
Below that sits the
Fabric Manager, which is
a regional level control plane.
And that comprises
a high level API
to configure virtual
networks and other functions.
And then you get
down to the OFE,
which is our open
flow layer, which
takes our API abstractions
and then converts those
into open flow configurations
and programs those constructs
directly to the switching layer.
And then the
switching layer itself
is a programmable software
switch based on Open vSwitch.
And that's the core data
plane for data processing.
So as an example
of how this works--
again, we talked about
internal load balancers.
So this slide here is about
how we separate, first
of all, the control
plane and the data plane.
So the VMC and
the OFEs are where
the control plane happens.
And those program
the data plane.
So in this case, what we've
got is control messages
being exchanged between
the client VM and CFEs
and also with the VM controllers
and the Cluster Fabric Manager.
We've got stats for
health reporting.
And we've also got
health checks happening
on the other end for load
balancing high availability.
And then finally you've
got VM to VM traffic.
Something to point
out here again
is typical load balancers
have middle boxes.
But our approach for the
ILB, as I described before,
is that we built
the load balancers
as distributed services.
So what's happening
is these health
checks are actually checking
services on backbends
across multiple backends.
And the client VM, in this
case, is where the load
balancer itself is running.
And we're programming
paths to those backends
directly into each of the
host, both forward and reverse.
So then we can also
extend those functions.
And I think the interesting
thing about this
is we can extend those functions
without changing typologies,
because again, we don't
have middle boxes.
So all we have to do is
configure the control plane,
so that we can update
the data plane to add
that new function into a path.
So if we add an on-prem
situation in a VPN,
it's very simple for us
to then program the flow
to the VPN termination point.
That programs the backends
that allow the load balancer
to connect to
those backend VPNs.
Again, we didn't
change any topology.
This was simply a
software-driven operation.
So let's talk about
network programming models.
So it's interesting
when you're doing
a software defined
network, you have
to program all of these flows.
You're not using distributed
routing technologies
to enable every device to
talk to any other device.
You're not using ARP,
for example, to say, OK,
who has this IP address?
We actually have
to install flows
for every single conversation
that could possibly happen.
So when we started, we started
by configuring full mesh
communications.
And that works really
well for small networks,
but it starts to get really
ugly for big networks.
And that's what this is showing.
This is actually a
quadratic scaling problem.
And in order to solve this, we
had to do something different.
So what we did is we came
up with a concept called
hoverboards.
Basically hoverboards
are a software gateway.
We use this to program
simple paths from every VM
through that software
gateway to any other VM.
So rather than
having a full mesh,
you traverse the hoverboard.
And we still preprogram
small networks.
So small networks
still have a full mesh.
Large networks have hoverboards.
And all those packets go
through the hoverboards.
And then if the
flows get too heavy--
in other words,
if the hoverboards
reach any scaling constraints--
we just offload those.
We actually program
a direct flow
into the client or
the two hosts that
need to talk to each other.
So by doing that,
this software gateway
allowed us to achieve some
really staggering scaling
improvements.
And what we found out in
one of the design questions
that we had to
ask ourselves when
we built those
hoverboards is actually
is this going to hurt by
putting these middle boxes
in between all of this?
So we get a scaling benefit from
that configuration and control
plane, but are we going to
suffer on the data plane?
And it turns out that
the vast majority of host
never talk to each other.
And then the vast
majority of hosts
that actually do talk to each
other are very, very quiet.
We're talking less than
100 kilobits per second.
And so basically we
have a threshold that
says, hey, anything that's
got a larger flow than this,
we'll just offload
that to the host.
So often times we get questions.
So how can I ensure that
my hosts will directly
talk to each other if I have a
latency sensitive application?
It's really simple,
send a lot of traffic.
So again, by implementing
the hoverboards
we were able to improve
programming times
by a factor of 37x.
So that was a really,
really important achievement
to scale this network
to the millions of users
that we now have.
We also found that we
could use hoverboards
to scale, not just between
VMs, but also between zones.
And so we just took
it to the next level
and said, OK, well, if
we've got hoverboards
inside the region
between VMs, we
also know that, OK, the
communications between two
hosts on different zones
is also likely to be quiet.
And it turns out that
that's also the case.
So what we did is
we also inserted
hoverboards between zones.
And so again, two hosts,
one in each different zone
in the same region.
The low bandwidth routes
traverse the hoverboards.
We do local stats.
This is also an interesting
detail of the hoverboards.
You might think that the
hoverboard itself is actually
measuring the size of the
bandwidth between the two
hosts.
But it's actually stats that
are driven from the host itself.
And that's to prevent
the hoverboard from right
at the moment when it
actually is suffering
or it needs more
resources, we're
not trying to make it more busy.
We can actually just offload
that to the host itself.
And the host itself can
create its own flows.
And this is another benefit
of distributing our network
functions across
the host themselves.
So when we see those stats
and the bandwidth is high,
we just go straight
host to host.
So again, this works just
like inside of a zone.
It's just one more
hierarchy of hoverboard.
So I'm going to switch gears
here now and talk about the way
that we do networking
at the host level.
And one of the
things that people
may find odd or at
least unique about us
is that we do all
of our networking
on the host level in user space.
And so first of all, why
do we do this in software?
And we'll get to the reasons
why we do this in user space,
but the primary reason is we're
able to get native hardware
performance in software.
Our fastpath, which is basically
just doing packet forwarding,
is able to push 3 million
packets per second
with one dedicated CPU per host.
And that translates to
greater than 30 gigabits
per second on ideal situations.
Then we also use code processors
for CPU intensive functions,
like denial of service
protection, IP rewrites, etc.
We'll talk more about
that in a second.
And then we also have
an on-host control plan.
And with an on-host
control plan,
we're able to do things like
live migrations and hitless
upgrades, because we can
just swap out the data plane
right underneath that control
plane without losing any state.
So, again, why
build in userspace?
Well, there are a
lot of advantages.
First of all, there's
security advantages.
It runs without root.
So pretty much the entire
data plane has no privileges.
And secondly, we can do things
like continuous fuzzing,
because the code
footprint is so small.
We can also do things like
address space randomization.
It also improves robustness.
So unlike a kernel bug, which
can take a whole machine,
a user process can go
down and come right back.
And likewise,
userspace processes
allow for nearly
weekly upgrades via
our hitless upgrade process.
Live migrations again
also allow for VMs
to be migrated
between physical hosts
without disruption, enabling
transparent host maintenance.
So it also provides a
flexible architecture.
So our data plane is
fully programmable.
The control plane
basically programs
open flow rules and
the data plane itself.
It's pretty simple.
The example on
this side, we have
three tables; N cap, D cap, and
maybe some special functions.
This all programs
the data plane,
which is a key action
base data plane.
And we've also enhanced
the overall vSwitch layer
to include things like
stateful load balancing, which
aren't available in your
standard implementation
of the vSwitch D. It also does
different features for us.
We've created custom
features for ourselves,
like stats and billing.
And we also have the ability
to do policy enforcement.
These network functions
are also applied directly
into the data plane
via code processors.
So again, coprocessors
outside of the fastpath,
which again, the
fastpath is primarily
just doing forwarding.
These functions
outside the fastpath
include things like
traffic shaping,
denial of service protection,
abuse protection, IP address
rewrites.
So for example, when you're
trying to send packets
to the internet, you have to do
a rewrite from that private IP
address to a public IP address.
All of that happens
in the coprocessor.
So a little bit of history
about our CPU efficiency
gains as we've
improved Andromeda.
First of all, when
we built this stuff,
it became very,
very evident that we
needed to minimize the
host and guest network CPU
cycles per byte.
And the way that we
did that was over
time moving off of
the host completely
and bypassing as much of
the guest as possible.
So in the Andromeda
1.0 implementation,
there was a kernel Open vSwitch
and the Open vSwitch control
plane on top and
then a hypervisor.
The kernel data path
only had support
for egress data offload,
but it didn't have support
for ingress data offload.
As a consequence, you can
see that that resulted
in a lot of host CPU cycles.
Andromeda 1.5 optimized
the host data path.
It added ingress offload
support, but still maintained
the kernel data path.
This optimization along
with the introduction of
receive offload support improved
both the guest and the host CPU
performance, and it also
allowed for live migrations,
which was a pretty big deal.
We couldn't do that before
we had ingress support.
But the real big evolution
came with Andromeda 2.0.
There, the entire
data plan was moved
into user space, where we still
required one thread of handoff.
So there was still a
software virtual NIC
that we had to talk to.
And so there was there
was a contact switch.
But as you can see, there was
still a significant reduction
in cycles per byte.
With 2.1, we moved that
one thread handoff.
And with 2.2,
we've added support
for memory copy offloads.
And that's led to a decrease
in more than 50 cycles per byte
since we started
with Andromeda 1.0.
So some throughput numbers.
On a single core
per host data plane,
again, the fastpath uses one
dedicated CPU on each host.
On one single core
per host for our data
pane on Skylake testbed
hosts, both hosts
connected to the same
Top of Rack switch.
We're able to get 38 gigabits
per second throughput.
Again, this is ideal
situation scenarios.
We don't support 38
gigabits per second in VMs.
All right, you're laughing.
I have something for you.
So anyway, we also
noticed some VM
to VM round trip time latency.
So again, with the
single core per host
and the same Top of Rack switch
on Skylake infrastructure,
we had normal TCP
round trip time
in the order of 25 milliseconds
with our TCP busy polling.
So we're not doing interrupt
driven networking anymore.
We were able to lower that
down to 15 milliseconds.
And with DPDK, we're
able to lower that
below 10 milliseconds.
All right, so a quick summary.
So what we talked about
today, global network.
Why is a global
network important?
It's easier to deploy.
You've got fewer things to do.
It's more reliable.
The infrastructure that we
built is heavily redundant.
It's more flexible.
You have the ability
to operate functions
both globally and locally.
We talked about Andromeda.
The key principles
between Andromeda
are isolation,
performance, and agility.
So isolation, again, we've
got performance and functional
isolation.
We have to keep all of these
network name spaces distinct.
And agility, we need to be
able to improve as we build.
And so this agility that
we've built into this
allows us to do weekly upgrades.
And then finally, some
network functions.
And by the way, this is by
no means complete-- uh, oh,
I gave away the ghost--
so anyway, these
network functions
are by no means a
comprehensive list.
Hopefully, you've been
spending some time with this,
and you know that there are
many global network functions,
there are many regional
network functions.
We only talked about a few.
And then I have one more
thing for those that
were snickering a little bit.
We are announcing
today that we support
32 gigabit per second
networking host to host.
The way that we talk about
networking in our cloud
is a general rule of thumb is
that you get about 2 gigabits
per second per vCPU.
So up until today, that scaled
up to 16 gigabits per second.
So on an 8 vCPU box, you could
get 16 gigabits per second.
Now, this requires
the Skylake platform.
However, with a 16
CPU Skylake platform,
you can get up to 32
gigabits per second.
It requires zero configuration.
There's no SR-IOV required,
no different drivers.
You can use a standard virtIO
driver and this will just work.
And with that,
I'd like to invite
you to go to the rest of
our networking breakouts
for the rest of the week.
There's an interesting
hybrid one tomorrow
that one of my
colleagues is giving.
And also, again,
9:00 AM tomorrow,
we have an IP addressing in the
cloud panel, which I think--
you know, I'm a
nerd, but I think
this is a really cool topic.
And then if you want to cloud
poster, go to g.co/poster,
where you can download one
or we will ship it to you.
We're done.
[MUSIC PLAYING]